deregulating lab-grown meat would you
eat a lab-grown burger I'll give it a go
I don't mind my main thought is you know
I think it's very interesting that the
iea The Institute of economic affairs
has a chance to come on a show like this
and talk about a disaster in the economy
that that partially they caused by
inspiring literature's economic policies
which were disaster and instead of
grabbing the ball by the horns and
talking about this disaster which is
damaging tens of millions of people's
lives they ask us to talk about
lab-grown meat and what do you think
about it about lab growing me about the
iea well you've done the Ia about
Ladbroke about you're not a fan of
either Technical Solutions are they not
to be considered uh properly when we're
looking at things like climate change
and the environment
yeah for sure if they work if they work
if they just how will you know if they
if they work unless you try them well I
think you should give them a go but if
you're just using them to distract me
your own disastrous economic advice then
I think it's probably not a good idea